You have finally finished your graduate work and clinical
fellowship after many years. And are excited to become
faculty at a research hospital studying the genetics of
cranial-facial development. You are soon presented with a case
where a family has a child with an ear
condition. Where the external part of the ears malformed
and enclosed to the outside environment. This is similar
to a set of phenotypes observed for a trait
called Microtia. A congenital underdevelopment of the
outer ear. Now let's continue this hypothetical a
little bit more. Groundbreaking work from another
lab has shown that a major cause of
Microtia, is caused by a particular allele
on Chromosome 14. It turns out that this
particular allele promotes enhanced expression of gene
Y, which is the gene that causes microtia.
You begin to hypothesize that you could develop
a drug that might change the effect of this
gene during development. To prevent children from developing
microtia. Assuming that the microtia allele on chromosome 14
directly effects gene y somehow. I want you
to tell me is the particular allele on chromosome
14 that's causing microtia likely in the coding
or non-coding region. And then I want you to
tell me what effect you need your drug to have to achieve the
desired effect of normal ear development. Explain your answer in the box here.